[Music]
hello everybody happy Monday oh hello my
name is Jonathan I'm here with Jordan
Jordan is this the first time we've been
on a stream together this yes this is
the first time we gonna stream together
I've always done pre-recorded yes
impression stuff together exactly the
first of many hopefully we are streaming
surge to you we have a preview build yes
that we were allowed to talk about and
post stuff on Friday and now here we are
on Monday and we're gonna be playing
sound this game and checking it out
answering your guys questions as best as
we can as best as we can we're just
gonna start the beginning here it's like
the first three entirely sure if it was
definitely the first three just because
this preview build begins with a like
two months later card thing I'm like
other my who knows well yeah it's uh
you're not playing a specific character
this time around you have choice of your
background oh okay I never played the
original so I actually have no context
for you were just this dude named Warren
who who was in a wheelchair and he like
joined the organization that makes like
all of the exosuit things okay I'll to
walk again okay and he would have a job
because robots were basically taking
control of everything as in real life
this character creator seems like uh
it's always weird in a like this one is
like a little better cuz like Dark Souls
it was like I'm gonna put a helmet on
like right away like never really
bothered that much the this one like a
little I feel like you see more your
character more often yeah I say unless
you do decide to I guess you could put a
helmet on that's true hey crime what's
uh people uh Charles asked him what
platform this is a PC build yes like we
said this is a preview build so there's
you know if there's any like weirdness
that's because this isn't the final
build of the game or anything like that
so this is where we begin we're just
waking up we're in like some prison or
something yeah we have no context for
why we're here I love the opening of
Mass Effect 2 I'm glad that we have very
similar yeah I guess I'm like oh this is
a very separate thing I'm seeing a
little screen tearing III realize
haven't messed with the settings do you
want it going in options and see if
there's any like these think is on it
might just be the build yeah or one
thing with PC games is whenever we're
like streaming because we have like all
these video outs and multiple like is
screen tearing becomes a an issue so let
us know if it's too bad we can try and
fix it but we might just have to live
with it
also do wonderful subtitles actually
real quick that's that's always a good
thing to have on the stream wait they
were around they were on so I guess that
announcements dialogue justly wasn't
important enough that's no good so you
have your very standard Souls like being
able to defend your light attack your
heavy attack which is a slight
difference from the first search where
it was mostly instead of a light and
heavy attack it was horizontal and
vertical and it's kind of the same
concept here this is more horizontal and
this is more vertical but it's
definitely like this is more of a
charged heavier right toning that down
maybe a little bit almost calling us out
for having a dgx 1070 in here we can
maybe upgrade it and Michael's always
got graphics cards on his desk
this is Barwon I'm sure Michael won't
miss one probably happy we get it off of
his back yeah thought I was talking
about those vsync yeah we could try and
adjust if it's a real big problem
maybe we turn it off I mean maybe
that'll fix it
Max is asking so how is Serge - how do
you feel about it as Sony played the
first as I say I enjoy it more so than
the first one I think combat is a little
bit faster and I like the changes that
they made to combat you no longer have
for example a like in the first one you
started out and you could heal three
times before you had to rest at your med
station with the darksouls bonfire
yeah and this one health is tied to the
battery charges that you use to
dismember people so if you keep
attacking someone you can replenish your
battery and keep healing yourself which
I can't do right now is I'm not wearing
a rig but it allows you to essentially
just travel for longer distances and I
mean Oh but blocking is still atrocious
and not good just don't block just roll
that's what I do why would you just go
down either more environment search -
yes instead of going through the once a
me Factory there's actually distinct
area so this is like the prison that we
start in the next area is a bit more of
a city and you can even go beyond that
to this kind of like outside the city
Oreste kind of yeah yeah can create your
own character yes you can we very
quickly went through character
customization someone saying that
there's no more proficiency anymore I
guess that was something in the first
one yeah can't get this dude out though
don't have a xse to get in your do weak
whoop forest
heck yeah forest man Grahams asking
about upgrades upgrades work primarily
the same way only instead of just
putting scrap into your character and it
would just increase your stats over time
now you kind of put scrap into a
specific yeah you can decide I want to
increase health I went in
Sam and I gotta increase my battery
efficiency to get a bit more choice in
how you develop your more more RPG
elements right there be a demo released
for the game not that I'm aware of
it's coming soon oh yeah it's September
violent Vic this is better than the
first one you were saying you feel like
it's better than the first yes I enjoy
this one a lot more than the first one
and the first one apparently has its
fans um it wasn't bad it was just very
linear the environments were yeah the
same I never played it but I was saying
before we started that it had interested
me because I always my idea like what's
the next thing that from software could
do would be like to go sci-fi with it is
I'm like man what about like dead space
but with Dark Souls combat and like and
that's what we got and that's this looks
like close it's not quite exactly that
but it kind of it's scratching some of
that it's going in a little bit of that
direction so it's like I'm like this
opening actually reminds me a lot of
dead space too running through like the
hospital gown and yeah let's put on some
real people clothes and there we go
actually there's a lot of dead space to
influence I can I can feel miss like the
that's the same like you're getting
there and then it puts the suit on you
see yeah I can transfer if I had 388
scrap to upgrade I could transfer all of
it I don't have enough but then I could
decide whether I wanted to put it into
health stamina and battery so I do have
a few module points right now so
to health and then we'll do two into
battery actually now we'll just do it
even across the board make it simple
when does the search to take place it
takes place after the events of the
first game I don't know how far into the
future it does I do know that I haven't
met the first game's protagonist but I
have found audio logs that make
reference to him so he's at least
mentioned in this game so he might still
be alive
let's try to the student has a nice
looking weapon
I do Det let's try to get her spear nice
come on let me cut it there we go oh my
god nice there's a gruesome like that in
the first one - yeah you can quickly
compare the things that you pick up to
see whether or not you want to equip it
immediately which I someone's saying
that that apparently the bad ending is
canon for surge oh that's interesting
that makes sense a little bit oh I
should probably go often do games do
that where they make the cannon and the
bad one the baton in the cannon ending I
think metro yeah did that although
that's like weird cuz technically that
was the cannon ending from the book that
was kind of a weird exception
I want your club please think oh yeah it
doesn't do that much more though so
we'll stick this for now don't do me a
favor and go back to the graphic
settings for a second turn off vsync I
just want to see if that corrects it a
little bit Mira's head compacted plate
oh that's why I was on granny go and
just turn this thing off I'm curious if
that will fix the screen tearing it off
you know made it worse
no I mean theoretically like the whole
idea is screen tearing ceasing supposed
to fix it I just heard back on we'll
stick with it I want it spend so much
time messing with all this yes he is
playing as a lady and speaker says this
game looks good yeah I mean I'm I gotta
admit I'm pretty uh pretty curious about
it's the 720 yeah the 720 windowed but
we're not in windowed mode so this is
this is 1080 I always wanted to be a
search-and-rescue guy
maybe we'll see each other around I do
kind of miss the fact that the
protagonist can't heard about three
alright in this one Warren actually did
have voice acting okay
I'm guessing they just didn't want to
have a voice actor for both the dude and
the girl and then to have it for all the
different dialogue choices that write me
Nick maybe it was just not in the budget
yeah isn't the worst thing in the world
but yeah I do like my protagonist to
talk to talk it depends on what kind of
game it is respawn they don't come back
after you kill them but they do come
back when you rest at a med station
which is essentially this games version
of a bonfire it's where you can heal and
upgrade yourself and Bank all the scrap
that you've collected so I want to know
if you can equip weapons right then and
there and you stopped to do it from the
mid day yeah so Revere I can Quinn yeah
use only weapon that I've picked up as
well as any armor if I happened to have
any which I do not
you know with my rig I can open this
door one autumn leaf says he never had
you from the mid Bay
I don't know I never like I said her
flight the first so I'm just assuming
all right so the warden doesn't want us
to escape
classic warden he's a cop
[Laughter]
I like want you to throw it like throw
it at like when you do that charge just
like oh I will say I do really like the
fact there seems to be a lot more
weapons in this one that have a lot more
attack animations yeah I'm really I hope
we get to the part where the staffs are
introduced because I really like the
staff which we're in the first game but
I think they just are better than this
better in this one
check with the Cavazos would be nice a
bigger destructible environment now be
interesting a Souls game that has like
destructible environments I wonder how
that would work let's say there almost
every Souls game is like so dependent on
pushing the person through the level of
a certain way a very crafted level I
wonder how that would work I'm sure that
wouldn't work or one could probably
figure it out though yeah it's weird
like I feel like environmental
destruction has kind of been like fully
abandoned but definitely less emphasized
in games recently I mean the only one of
recent note is probably CG which yes
it's entire gameplay right like
crackdown 3 multiplayer mode which was
also very much scaled down from what it
was kind of the original concept as it
was it's like battlefield doesn't really
emphasize it the same way like it's cool
in there but it's not like like a bad
company to like literally everything
could be destroyed by the end of the map
it's just there's nothing to hide behind
all right I got two more modules going
to put them into health and stamina
and now this person is back because I
rested at a mid station but if I loot
this item again I will get upgrade
materials for and the one that I
currently have
so I collect enough of them I can just
make this stronger all right gotta go
take on the warden he is the last dude
stop Calum getting out and I'm assuming
the first boss that you face in this
game makes sense this is very much a
tutorial area hello see ya there was
something with nanites in the first
games I'm guessing that's what that is
but so yeah he's got a lot more health
and he's got a lot of armored pieces on
him he also has a drone so he can attack
from range Hester says this game makes
me want to nuke dead space oh my god I
love Annie dead space you're a big dead
space fan I am such a big day in space
fan
I was devastated when Oh No
that's the thing is like I don't know if
I don't need a new dead space but I need
a new dead space like game mm-hmm like I
need another game that's in that same in
that same horror but very survival yeah
like very combat heavy you know to this
day I still just love the fact that
everything that Isaac pretty much uses
in that game except for the assault
rifles yeah hacked engineering equipment
and he's just using as a weapon exactly
like I mean you know Resident Evil 2
remake scratches some of that itch but
it's definitely more survival horror
than dead space and I actually really
like that about it but I feel like
there's like there's room for both
mm-hmm I want I want one that's a little
more like action dead Spacey yeah now
here is the one cool addition to the
surge to is like in the first game you
do have a time limit to pick up the
scrap that you dropped I've never seen
that execution animation before but in
this one when you stand near your fallen
scrap that will heal you so you can
either pick it up immediately like you
would in most all right wells like games
or you could be a cocky prick like I am
and be like I'm going to try to leave it
on the ground for as long as possible to
get that health bonus knowing that if he
kills me or if I forget to pick it up
and I'm I'm going to lose it forever I
like that that's a cool mechanic that's
a fun little twist is this only for Xbox
we're playing a PC build so it's at
least on PC and Xbox
I would assume ps4 buy yeah it's not
sure I'm pretty sure it's ps4 Xbox one
and PC yeah it's almost saying that
they're gonna play the first one because
it's on game pass it is yes I guess you
have a game pass I am game pass now
because I picked it up for that oh no
you lost all your stuff yeah
I picked it up for the for the gears 5
beta mm-hmm I was like well I guess I
have this game past now for at least a
month so I was like looking through and
you know what they have that I was like
I've been mean to play it and I was like
outer wilds on game pass and that's one
of those games I'm like I should play it
cuz everyone keeps talking about it and
I was like I guess I'll pick it up on PC
whatever and I'm like oh no nevermind
game pass I say we have like half of the
office being like it's a great game and
the other half of office mean like
haven't played it yet yeah exactly so my
gosh probably play that if you have game
pass
ultimate you can play on PC as well
that's true I should look at that I
should see what my options are yeah so
you could play it on PC yeah I guess so
hmm interesting you have choices options
well wait can you look cause it's it's
like isn't it um epic only on PC though
otherwise it is so with I don't know how
that works would it not be on like the
game store Windows Store I'm getting
questions hey I'll be honest I'm getting
real frustrated with all that epic
nonsense because I'm just
I can never like what where can i buy
this video game I just need to know
where I can buy it
there's too many stores it's too many
stores and like any time I have to like
Google like what store do I have to like
like load up to and stop by a game on
just like that's too much
now I could go for his less armored
right arm to kill him more quickly but
this dude has a very good weapon I think
we're trying to gather one that's fair
he probably is one of the better early
game weapons that you can get oh nice
okay 45 seconds I have enough time to
get that scrap at some point
hit me
I should probably pick that up at some
point
no gotta get it nice hey girl
give me your arm nice cool all right I
don't want to say anything cuz I don't
want to distract me but one autumn leaf
says that you can attack his weak spot
and then you just hits you swap to the
weapon and then cut it off at the last
second so they're saying you could
potentially do it that way okay I know
that you definitely could in the first
game so you're thinking maybe they
changed it and this one's I've noticed
that like some of the body parts have
like certain armor things on them that
you have to wear down the armor before
you can cut it off so I have no idea
what this is like I found a few terms
but remember that show that was real
good for one season and like the only
reason I remembered it at all is because
they cast one of the heroes actors for
the upcoming season of flash which one I
cannot remember his name so all I
remember I remember
funny enough the reason I was interested
is when I watched when I watched it the
main character Peter he would he played
uh one of the characters that Rory dates
and Gilmore Girls and that sounds like
odds the guy from Gilmore Girls and that
was like such a weird reason to get it
feel like oh okay cool uh and then they
made his character like super
overpowered so then they had to nerf him
in the second season and it was just
hold that whole thing was a mess oh then
Sylar and then Silas character became
like
he became a you know like Spock and
stuff and he got he's like one of the
few guys who like had like a big career
outside of that I guess he'd hidden
patear also did some stuff she ended up
in until dawn unfortunately did not save
her now in either I messed that up
squid son squid there is a giant squid
over there yes what's up with that squid
and that's where we have to go heck yeah
I want your weapon please okay you can't
even try can you kill him I will try
after this that hair look good zoom
there front of your hair I do look good
you know what this is a game that seems
to have actual black hair options right
that was the thing we talked about a
while ago about how video games never
have like black hair options swing oh
yes do it do it again do it again yeah
my god okay you nearly died that's what
you gotta get it man ooh
hopefully I hopefully he'll forget about
that oh he's just gone alright fair I
would have real brother Eli's gonna be
pissed with me now when I don't go to
meet him so yeah alright this guy looks
like it's dying
I love this dude I love him so much
because he'll ask you like who are you
and you can be like what does it matter
he's like it matters tell me you can
either to say oh I'm a good guy or you
can just tell him I'm a bad guy who says
that bad to the bone oh yeah oh my god
and when you say it
he just pieces out like if you tell him
that you're a bad person he just uses a
grapple hook and just dips that was
weird and you don't get the questline
that he gives you - that's cool
people don't talk like that but that's
cool
I probably don't have enough scrap to uh
no idea and more health actually let's
put it all in till all right so yeah new
environment new place it doesn't look
like that yeah police station that's
some good sound it sounds like it hurts
I like how the same here is you yeah I
into the environments of this game like
it looks looks different ah dang I
attracted the intention of that dude
over there
[Music]
all right maybe get that one I'll have
just enough battery left to heal as well
nice no no your torso oh yeah that's not
like this guy because I'm not good
weapon has it just like launches people
yeah it just completely knocked him out
of his attack so I'm saying how you can
parry and you mess much with parries hi
I tried in this game but much like Dark
Souls I am NOT not very good at it yeah
that was always music while in the game
that actually got me to like get good at
pairing with blood-borne because it's
like it's like that that gun attack is
like so good if you like learn how to
use it right yeah I would always just
throw on a blunderbuss so I did have a
bit more of a ranger I want you go too
far dang it
give me your leg please thank you it's
an interesting question someone's asking
how the character moves around does it
feel unrealistically light is there a
realistic heaviness similar to GTA or
read dead that looks more light kind of
like a Dark Souls yeah you're pretty
nimble even when you are sadly outfitted
not really that animation priority in
the movement it's more than though in
the the attacks is I'd say where that
heaviness comes into play which is
really kind of souls games where it's
like very light movement
I can't imagine playing a Souls game
with like Red Dead level of light
weighty movement to it I think I would
hate it yeah it's just like wouldn't it
feel good to me hello I feel like people
can use that first time speedrun that's
the speedrun tactics it can like launch
you and then you can skip this whole
area this is game for ps4 as far as I'm
aware it is I should check because
there's a lot of people who seem to be
under the impression that it's like only
for Xbox so like it's definitely for PC
because we're playing a PC bit yeah
but I'm gonna check now now yeah
be a sport yeah all platforms like it
make sense for it
I feel like the future of a game like
this is implementing Dark Souls is
invasion mechanic and then being able to
cut the armor and weapons off of other
people that you invade oh so if you do
that would you like they lose that
weapon what do you mean would he do that
yeah baby dirty though yeah I could you
like you're like no that hate that
weapon that that unique weapon you got
off that boss is mine now you don't get
that anymore
and then your only way to get it back is
to go find someone else and invade them
and steal it oh actually it would be
hard but any real hard that'd be pretty
brutal I'm into that though that's a
cool idea oh that's a cool one say I'm
trying to put together the entire
scavenger armor set because when you do
you get like health pack for executing
people autumn leaf is saying imagine
Dark Souls with breath of the wild
weapon durability Oh God
hello yeah I don't know how I'd feel
about that the weapon durability and
breath of the wild already he's my least
favorite part about that game yeah I'm
not I don't love it I don't hate it I
like get it but it it I don't know I'm
very I very mixed feelings on it I would
feel a lot better about it if you could
actually find a weapon that wouldn't
break yeah well there's like the master
start right and then suck it yeah
I members like the Hylian Shield but
even then I think the hylene shield does
of it does break and you can go back and
get it again you have to go through the
like basement dungeon of the castle but
it does eventually break yeah I'm yeah
I'm just not into that
no this dude is I'm curious if will
adjust any of that stuff err for a while
too
it's a viable strategy Frost I really
wants to see you do a directional parry
when autumn says I think if they break
you should be able to find a blacksmith
to repair it you know what yeah sure
yeah yeah yeah oh that might actually be
what fixes my my problem if they just
add like a like a repair mechanic to
breath of the wild I think I'd feel a
lot better about it it's when it's like
you know that weapons just gone it
shattered into a billion pieces
yes
is that a Konami code up up down down
left right left right ex yeah I thought
you might be
[Laughter]
hello peoples who wants to fight first
that guy does nope maybe not or he
doesn't never mind
grenades are cheating Oh God Jesus we
are playing a limited build this is a
preview bill that has like the first
three areas of the game and that is what
we are checking out right now screen
tearing much yes sorry we unfortunately
couldn't get that that fixed I think I
might look into some stuff with that cuz
it I have a feeling it might also be
because I think this monitor is a like
1440p monitor but we have to stream in
1080 for like the capture purposes so
that might be about him no no no bummer
no vital signs round womp womp
you think you're gonna you're gonna like
play this game when it comes out I think
so yeah I'm enjoying it a lot more than
the first one and I did somewhat enjoy
the first one so yeah I am interested
it's kind of depend on what else is out
because it's coming out in September if
I recall there's a lot of really good
things come out in September and there's
a lot of really good things coming out
in November as well yeah and even less
so but still a couple of good things in
October a lot of things coming out
pretty heavy ladder and 2019 no offense
to the surge but they might be a little
higher my priority
I do get want to give this game a chance
cuz I do think it looks good it's just
coming out at a yeah a little rough tide
I feel for them yeah one autumn just
those are accepted for cyberpunk as is
everyone thankfully we got awhile for
that
still
I feel like once that game comes out
it's gonna be like I think we're all
just going to stop playing whatever
we're playing yeah I think that's sort
of like because there's a lot of games
coming out next spring and I think
that's coming out like looks like one of
the last games of that like big chunk of
games that are coming out and like a
Final Fantasy and like watchdogs it
comes out like at the end of that which
is good because it's like okay let me
play all those other games first and
then ways possible I'm gonna go hard
it's kind of my breath a little wild if
it was like all right play everything
else and I'm Bertha miles out we're all
just gonna be playing this
you can do this well they got that
clicking jump - yeah it's like yeah and
I never liked that in Dark Souls ever
say Sakura spoiled me now I know my a
proper proper jump button this comes out
in September it does comes out real soon
I think it's September like like and the
September yeah I like the 2027 something
like that twenty-fourth purpose
September
little and open this gate up so I have
this shortcut back to the medbay if I
need to and then also because you had a
September we got oh boy we've got
Katherine full body mm-hmm
we got gears five oh that's that's the
big on the tenth no cuz three days later
Borderlands 300 and uh on the six so
four days before that monster hunter a
world ice born of course and then on the
17th we got destiny to shadow keep but
don't worry on the 20th we got legend of
zelda links awakening and then the surge
to you on the 24th yah a really packed
month holy crap yes yes it is because I
know for a fact jeez yeah I'm sure you
and me are probably gonna do Borderlands
3 I think we I think I think we're the
only people in the office Lilly was the
only other one who really cared about
Borderlands maybe she'll be back and
hopefully even if she isn't she's going
to be messaging us somehow some oh I'm
sure yeah she'll message me and she'll
find it so yeah we'll definitely be
covering that and then it's like alemana
I just got back into destiny so I'm
actually like really excited for shadow
keep so man that's a lot little boy and
then October's call it Duty Luigi's
Mansion three death stranding is in
November Pokemon Jedi fall an order doom
eternal God Shenmue 3 god super monkey
mob banana blitz HD that's the real
winner yeah heck yeah yeah as a packed
packed rest of the year a lot of look
forward to so surge was very linear
search to less so I could just run
straight at these two dudes one has
heavy armor
and Molotov and the other one has an A K
that can just demolish me pretty much
instantly but I could also just go down
here and then sneak around them and then
try to backstab the gunner and then it's
easier to take them on so we're going to
try to do that hmm code van comes out
September does it oh my god
horses like please yes it does it comes
out three days after the search - good
boy well I'm probably only gonna end up
playing one of them I don't think I can
play two souls likes at the same time
yeah um
September seems to be the month like I
mean there's definitely a couple really
big games coming out like November like
you know obviously just stranding and
doom and Pokemon but like there's in
terms of a month packed with the most I
think September is going to be the most
brutal to be honest
why couldn't any of these games have
come out in the first half of 2019 it
isn't to say that the first half of 2019
was a boring eat half of the year but
this is why into the year game of the
year conversations are so difficult
because everyone's like let's just all
put something out right at the end which
then of course makes my December so
freaking hard yeah hmm what are you
looking forward to the most the most
yeah I II was surprised with how much I
enjoyed a Jedi fallen order because it
kind of has a very sucky Rove I banned
all some like Metroid your stuff you
have been doing locks and abilities to
navigate the world so yeah looking
forward to battle - actually that sounds
like a fun time
can't no I will not die here
I need your rifle oh I'm gonna burn to
death there it is suck here wasn't a
Souls like it wasn't but it had souls
like mechanics and features in it man
check girls good that's a good game I
wonder if we're gonna get DLC for it oh
you know I don't even think about
because it kind of looks like from
software's just moving on to the Eldon
ring game which isn't bad
I'm some software it's just always
moving forward and like there it's it's
funny like this is probably suck your Oh
between suck your oh and Dark Souls 3
was probably the longest like break it
was like that period from like Dark
Souls 2 to blood-borne to dark it was
just like every year yes another game it
was like okay the new fromsoftware
game's gonna come out and in you know
spring like you know May but then don't
worry because at e3 they're gonna
announce their next one and they just
keep doing that every year and they are
kind of starting that again where
they're like yep
here you go next game next game we've
already announced it it's like okay cool
cool do we know if Felton ring supposed
to run next year I don't think they have
released I assumed next year but elven
rings also supposed to be very different
I supposed to open world was kind of a
big thing
did they ever confirm any of that stuff
because I was all like the rumor I say
yeah the only thing that we have
confirmed is the trailer that we got
that george RR martin yeah involved in
some capacity I wonder what his
involvement was if it was a like a
consulting thing if he actually was like
a writing credit
I'm curious because you know no offense
George are mine I don't feel like I
never felt like um you know I never felt
like from software necessarily needed
someone like him in order because
typically it's like I don't know you
know like a studio that like makes
really good gameplay but maybe their
world building or their storytelling
isn't like the best and you're like oh
but they got George are Martin so
they're like combining the talents of of
his world building with their you know
game design is right from software's
always had a really good world building
and game design so I'm like I'm curious
what what unique flavor he will exactly
bring to to their game I say we'll find
out yep we'll find out I am curious to
see if the what is it prosthetic
mechanics are coming back to in some
capacity because it looks like one of
the characters and the driller was using
yeah yeah yeah do you think it's gonna
be yeah is it gonna mechanically build
off of psyche rowers are gonna be its
own thing because I would actually
really like a proper secular sequel in
the sense that I think they could refine
those mechanics more and like make them
really good like it was already really
good but I think they could they can
improve and make that game like really
really good they can really just go in
on stealth and now exactly like it's
really the stealth stuff I'm like I
think they can go real real hard on that
stuff and make it really good anyway
surge - we haven't talked about that
it's just if you enjoyed the first surge
I think there's enough here here to
enjoy it yeah exactly I said if you it
seems like they're making some smart
changes there honestly reinventing the
game but it again I haven't played it so
I'm just kind of talking from what it
seems like people have been saying but
it looks like they're making the
improvements and changes that fans of
the first will be happy with yes I say
I'm not sure though there's enough here
to convince you to pick it up if you
didn't didn't like the first one okay
interesting yeah makes sense I mean the
environments are new there are new
weapons there are a lot of new mechanics
since but it's not a different game
ah stop moving I need two dimensions DMC
five better like better combat I guess
insecure oh that's so open hello
apparently my phone does not understand
that it was a very different ones like
what what are you talking about uh very
different games but man definitely cry
excellent game a very very good game
like that game a whole lot what you like
that game no shocker right it's almost
like I wouldn't shut up about it like
when it came out I definitely a lot of
real good games that came out the
beginning of the year that I'm oh right
that came out too that was an excellent
game Capcom Capcom has been killing it
this year
we guys be streaming Youngblood I think
we're I'm sure there will be some sort
of stream I don't know why we typically
stream all the big games in some
capacity
it's been this game is coming out on
September 24th pretty soon I say this
Friday is pretty heavy because we have
killa kill if Oh warehouses and
Wolfenstein oh shoot is well it's been
this week yeah that's right oh boy
ooh and Friday's community Fridays I
mean Ben you have choices choices with
we like to play a multiplayer game so
we'll probably do kill a kill Ben the
embargo will have just passed yeah that
might we might do kill a kill on Friday
because we could do some online matches
forgot about that game I think most
people did it's coming out along with a
few other big heavy hitters yeah cuz um
yeah which one do I dive into right can
I was think I'm gonna have to postpone
Wolfenstein as much as I hate myself for
it
just because I'm playing three houses
and killer kills I might do Wolfenstein
because it's shorter so maybe like get
that out of the way first for me because
um me and my girlfriend were trying to
figure out like the next game we want to
play cuz we played through all
Borderlands 1 & 2 and then we tried
playing pre sequel and she didn't really
like it she's like I don't like this
game and I'm like that is a rare
complaint that is a common criticism not
as good it's not a bad game it's just
she's not digging it the way she's like
the other ones
so she's debating whether she wants to
actually like keep playing it or not
uh-huh
but so we're trying to look at that so
she's trying to figure out what else to
play and she was like well we could do
like Wolfenstein co-op maybe bins like I
think we're playing Wolfenstein huh
frecce was that what we're doing as a
site for a thing oh you know what yeah
we might have like a PMM type thing for
Wolfenstein
hmm that's it you're probably playing
Friday okay we'll figure that up I guess
all when I get out of here I'll figure
out what's up with all that but the
other option was we were thinking about
oh maybe we'll play fire and blonde
because even though it's not a
multiplayer game it's that kind of game
that's like you and a friend or you know
a girlfriend this case can sit down and
play it together and make decisions like
like oh we should pick this house or we
should romance this person or we should
do this so we kind of want to do both of
those I say you could totally have one
person play for the first house and then
on a subsequent playthrough have someone
yeah play for the second
even just like the combat because it's
like turn-based you can like be like we
should do this no we should do this it's
kinda making those decisions qex
vanassa's the song from the first game
back I assume they're talking about
surge the game we're playing song do you
know what they're talking about
[Music]
what's song and particular I mean Serge
has a soundtrack if you can clarify for
us we would love to now the prison song
I'm not sure what there I didn't play
Serge so I am sorry I have no idea what
you're talking about but it could just
be my ignorance Roadrunner wants to know
if this game is combo this like the
first one kind of ish I think they
turned that back yeah I think it more so
just wants you to decide whether or not
you're gonna use a light attack or a
heavy attack and how much you're gonna
charge it you can charge both of them
another mystical thingamajig one autumn
leaf says hold heavy light heavy hold
heavy you trust me it's brutal all right
you've sold me so no idea what this is
what it looks like this girls forced
pushing a bunch of people cool
no idea what the could mean but that
entails hey come up here I don't want to
go down they were everyone else's so you
come to me
alright alright let's dance let's dance
nice nice and give me your arm
and we'll say that like this is pretty
much it for in terms of combats just
it's just that remember repeat dismember
repeat a goose and the chat saying the
surge getting a sequel
that's right goob and guess what it
comes out in like a two months
it comes out real soon you don't have to
wait long at all is this an indie game
I'd say it's more your mid tier double-a
kind of vein which you know what I never
know what to call this I know like
they're not they're not like Halo or
here your your B games your B games I
don't know I'm just happy that games
like this still exist everyone well you
know what I mean like it's it's been so
either it's real small indie games or
its giant triple-a the middle class of
video games is dying Bernie Sanders just
gonna bring it back for us yes
[Laughter]
but no I'm glad that games like this
still get to exist game needs to be a
big triple-a game
she had a rough time with the first one
if I remember yeah yeah it was kind of
saying how he thought the first one was
I don't know it wasn't really doing much
for him personally it's not a bad game
yeah he's also weirdly particular with
his games they're an area they're people
happy yes that one guy who asked for it
30 minutes ago was real happy if you
still here
can you get a gun is that like a thing
you can get attach it to your drone okay
I'm like what is the word for that
flying machine that people sometimes use
okay all right
boobs asking yeah fits more the same
noticeable improvements we feel like
you're saying how you feel like it's
definitely improved yeah but it is also
a lot of the same so if you weren't
really diggin the first one you're
probably not gonna dig the second one
it's probably gonna feel the same for
you but but if you liked the first one
you're gonna be like wow there's
improvements that I asked for and yeah
that seems to be the case so yeah Travis
is saying he couldn't get into the first
one his biggest issue was combat speed
feel very clunky and very slow but
they'll give the second one a try what
do you feel like the speeds may be a
little bit faster yeah and I like that
you're able to regain your health by
just attacking which is very blood-borne
of them yeah before you had to like hold
on to your uh what is it like a specific
amount of items very dark Souls yeah so
it makes combat just a little faster
like you're encouraged to just get into
someone's face even if it means like
you're about to die like I am I believe
in you at lunch oh right bummer but
blocking is still garbage and they
sometimes that girl says they were
finding the boss difficulty in the first
one to be a problem that's fair
bosses are still fairly tricky and this
one like I think the only reason I did
halfway decent against the first two
boss as I count the dude you have to be
to get your exosuit a boss that's this
guy doing up here just because I've
played this previous hello times what's
above the banner I was like that guy's
just rotating what happens and also
smaller than you I was very confused I
touched the banner and I got tech Scrat
okay
oh good mentions let it die oh man that
was a game I wanted to like because of
that Sudha Sudha weirdness but that
games like free-to-play economy was not
great no it was real bad in my opinion
there's a shame because it had like a
great concept had a great concept but
yeah it's like free-to-play economy was
really not great and then I found its
environmental design to be really boring
but I had stuff I liked about it yeah
exactly like been saying I like the idea
of let it die there's these good things
in there but like uncle death but
instead you could do the wrestling moves
on people but you very quickly hit that
like free-to-play paywall and then it
just wasn't it wasn't built very very
well take out the dude with the rifle
first
ashin was your favorite souls like game
that's not it from the software game
that's what we loved dashing I looked at
a lot I need to go back and play more of
it I started it and I got almost like
just starting to really get into it and
then I kind of got distracted I was so
disappointed that the game came out
right at the time that we were doing
like it yeah I cannot convince any of
these people that this game is good your
your shadow on your weapon is uh doing a
thing what thought yeah I really liked a
lot about that game from when I played
of it and I definitely should go back
and play more of it Neos up there Niels
another one that I never liked played
all the way through but I liked what I
played a bit a lot billy samurai we're
getting a lot more souls like games
where you can decide what character you
want to be searched you add a character
creator neo added a character creator
yeah they're kind of going it's funny
like all the souls like games are now
going character creator Wow from
software when the opposite action it
went to fixed character no idea why yeah
I think both kind of work like I liked
having just like you know you just play
a sucky row and Sakura like I think for
kind of what the story they were trying
to tell it worked really well
I appreciated the change of pace I just
got here but are you guys recommending
this game you were saying that if you
like the first one that there are
improvements to this one that will be
people will be happy with yes if you
play the first one and you didn't like
it you said this probably isn't gonna
change your mind probably not I am
enjoying this a little bit more than
code vein though so if you're trying to
decide just yes game to play and they do
come out three days apart which is a
thing
that is definitely a thing like
comes out in the 24th and code veins on
the 27th of September so I guess you're
probably gonna have to pick which one
there and more interested in Cohn vain
aesthetically but I have granted I
haven't played it personally but
everything I've seen about the combat
looks I don't know it's not it doesn't
look like it's doing it for me
I like how crazy that that character
creator is though that code main
character you read all this I got either
people yeah that is some of the most
anime a scare to creature I've ever seen
but at the very least they'll be a very
good monster factory episode about it
I'm sure but like when Jake and I were
playing it it's like water
what are we supposed to be doing in this
key yeah you guys were playing co-op
right mm-hmm yeah I guess that's the
other thing that's potentially
interesting about that one is that you
can like play the whole thing co-op your
friend but you can never really fully do
in other games although we weren't
entirely sure if you could play the
entire game co-op because the normal
level you we couldn't play co-op but we
were wondering like is it just because
it was the tutorial oh yeah and then
what is it you could do these like
blood-borne chalice dungeon like things
and you could do those where I go up
yeah those were kind of designed to be
co-op and blood-borne goob yeah it got
pushed back like multiple times code fan
that ain't supposed to have been out
like a couple years ago I feel like I
think so yeah yeah what you know that's
fine if they you know gonna be a better
game but I'm worried that that just kind
of means they may be announced it too
early and and the original excitement
around that game could have been kind of
diminished at this point probably and
then it's coming out with a real busy
time mmm yeah I can't remember what it
was coming out around last year I think
it was
also September and I cannot for the life
of me remember oh gosh
remember last year last year the words
that that was rough to watch because you
could like it's just like slowly - so
it's like could he get back is there a
way you can get back there nope nope
nope nope no think rampant monkey wants
to know our opinions on The Witcher
series what we think of it so far on
Netflix specifically likes I'm like not
just what you don't like it's been out
for a while now the Netflix series I am
pretty excited about it
I think visually it looks really good I
say the only complaint I think that
people in the office really had was that
that one shot yeah there was the one
shot of him where he's like in like bed
like and he's like kind of ripped and
you know like nervous and yeah it's like
something about like the perspective of
the shot like his body looks really
weird it's just like that one shot looks
really strange and bad but everything
else looked like pretty good it looks
like they're putting a lot of effort in
the production values I'm actually like
pretty okay with Henry what's his name
Carol oh yeah he looks fine like Kelly's
not happy but well she's not happy
because she doesn't like him but then
she thought he looked fine in it and I
think it's like her wrestling with that
this is my theory she likes Carol a lot
we were saying like Mads Mikkelsen is
like the ideal because like Paul think
of Carol is he's just like rugged kind
of like unconventional handsome mm-hmm
we were like oh he's like rugged and all
messed up looking but he's like kind of
attractive
that yeah that is based on The Witcher
uh based on the novel that's why he's so
different oh yeah yeah I'm aware of that
yes but I mean he's like the game is
obviously based on the book so the game
was trying to match his aesthetic I mean
it's just different because you know
that's uh that's how it be when you try
and adapt something live-action I'm very
curious though like I think it's
exciting that it is based on the books
cuz it gives us a chance to tell those
stories that a lot of people would never
like bother to read you know and then
like that in turn kind of benefits the
games because it's it's fascinating when
you go and read the books and then you
play the games you have a very different
like perspective all my characters write
stuff that's like actually like kind of
enhances those games a lot so it's like
I'm excited for people to like see the
series and then go back and play the
games and I've like a better
appreciation for certain characters like
yennefer and Cirie and all that stuff
especially in three like specifically
three years where they go real hard on
like introducing book elements more so
than one and two so I am kind of like
you said excited for the series for that
reason yes I just cannot bring myself to
read sure the books I recommend molasse
you want to the last wish is a very it's
an easy read and it's just a bunch of
short stories and apparently the the
first season is gonna be based a lot on
those which I'm kind of curious now
because it is just a bunch of short
stories so is this first season but
which are gonna be more like episodic
where it's like each episode is just one
of the short stories like I'm kind of
curious how they're handling that but
they also have stuff like Syrian
Jennifer in there yeah frozen last wish
but Siri not really like that's later
this is the first episode actually has
some references the last wish but it's
barely there okay yeah I don't really
know I'm not like I'm not me shaking
here I'm not fully aware well I just
it's more that I haven't paid it too
much attention to the news like I watch
the trailer but I don't read much about
it so I don't know if it's like oh are
they like going hard on the last wish or
they is it more just like they're taking
a couple things I wish I wish I knew
more about The Witcher talk about it
that's fun it's a series that is mostly
past me I mean not for lack of trying
I don't know I think the last wish would
be a solid solid first thing to adapt
because it's just a good way to
introduce you in each episode sort of
its own like monster the weak standalone
story like it and that's just like it's
a good way to kind of like get excited
and then and then and then if they want
you do your second season and that's
where you go to like the Blood and Ellis
trilogy where it just goes real deep
into like politics and like super
hardcore like Game of Thrones either
type stuff so you have like they're
probably first season to introduce the
concept and then it's like alright now
we're gonna go real deep into this the
political stuff in nitty-gritty the
nitty gritty we're going for about
another 15 minutes I don't know what I'm
doing anymore no worries
wait to have a good time you guys think
of the class action lawsuit against
Nintendo I'm not aware that what's the
what's the reasoning
may the spark guide you
may the father of understanding guide us
maybe all father light your way keyless
life may the makers blessing be upon you
just gonna keep listing ya all the
different semi quasi-religious things
you can say from a videogame pinion
Batman vs. ninja turtles phenomenal
comic ok movie was it may the good blood
something up the good blood and what's
the one in blood-borne blood-borne may
the good blood guide you or something
something up the good blood Ben we need
to ask Lucy or Tanner tell definitely no
I'm shame that I don't know right as a
huge blood-borne advocate Oh apparently
it's not the joy Khan analog stick drift
mmm yeah I think I remember now I think
someone is suing Nintendo that they know
that there's a drift problem they're
doing nothing to solve it I thought they
I thought they didn't then they wasn't
that the issue where they put like you
would send it in they'd fix it for you I
think so
Vince is what happened else I can't
Final Fantasy 14 names again
this area is neat it is it kind of this
is basically what the first game looks
like all the time all the time okay sure
this environment god which got really
boring mmm
so it's nice that now it's just one area
in this game right that's nice oh crap I
forgot you makes it turret no nice cause
you can make another one oh yeah how's
the cool move I love this desk cuz they
can just hit no no more nice oh this is
like a one-hit thing
oh ah so violent I'm not even a sharp
edge so the fact that you're able to
like will rip his arm off right that's
gotta be real unpleasant gotta go
through the armpit that's soft meat the
joint is it's like when you when you're
breaking a part of a chicken you know
gonna find the join just right there
yeah don't trust the cops
I can't remember if I'm about to be
ambushed or not I don't think so he just
assumed always always assumed hello
almost every bad person in the videogame
bees names a little something is never
little right person like I can be real
aggressive right now or I can try to be
sassy and be like oh I can't hear you
who are cutting the connection he just
hangs up yep cool I have no idea if
there's some sort of morality system in
this game I don't think that there is
but I'm ready to fix the ending I mean
it first game had multiple endings you
did
can't make that oh yeah Raymond monkey
says it's funny everything's high-tech
but he still use 1980s telephones yeah
that like dial tone no time ring oh I
missed early asked any opinion on Batman
versus Ninja Turtles I have no opinion
on that other than the fact that
ten-year-old me you would have been real
into it dang and I don't have enough
power to equip both legs at the same
time do I have any bullets left got
three bullets nope I have zero bullets
cool hey chainsaw hand man how's it
going can you do with that giant wrench
I just beat him with it I tell you do
some gnarly stuff like put its head in
there or something like
nice
I win whoo all right
nice nice nice I was about to say exact
same thing sounds like scooter it's the
same back now definitely not this is a
Mikey Newman I'm scooter yeah yeah and
he's uh he's he's just those movies with
Mike you know the whole reason he did
scooters cuz he worked at gearbox
because gearbox has a lot of their voice
actors are like actual employees yeah
well it's not very strong scooter was
great I'm gonna miss scooter I'm gonna
miss him so much
this scooter was real good I really
liked the stuff they did with scooter in
the commander's bloweth DLC like that
was nice I felt happy to have him have
his like final send-off his closure yeah
oh I just need to give him one Tex crap
sure I can't so they all every character
has like a different accent like that
guy was like hey y'all and this guy's
like ello gov'nor like what are they
going for I'm not good in the
post-apocalyptic world Texas in the UK
just collided in yes I'm really not sure
what they're going for
I'll tell you yeah I don't know I'm not
sure it's going on like what they're
going for
he's Gideon the third well I have to go
on my own because there's no co-op in
this game yeah it's something I'm really
excited for a watchdogs Legion just all
those great like UK accents they're
gonna pull out for that I'll be fun
50/50 on it
yes I'm because I really enjoyed to yeah
and I really did enjoy wine I never I
never played one and I never finished -
I kind of liked her back and play cuz I
actually liked I did like like Marcus a
lot as a character like I thought that
stuff is really cool yeah I'm like how
is that gonna work right like how's it
gonna feel like a story if all your
characters can die yeah I'm like what if
you just kill all of your characters
yeah rampant monkey yeah he's not like
full British either he just had like a
kind of a cockney accent but he wasn't
it was yeah I'm not really sure what
they were going for that one
Oh God he split it
can you get that weapon I'm gonna try I
want to see that nope nope no not gonna
get it you wanna call it here all right
we got five more minutes you want to it
want to give it or if you think you're
good we could just call it I'm not gonna
be able to get back all right well let's
just call it here then all right guys
thank you for watching
I was surged to a pretty pretty good
look at the game mm-hmm
first three first three areas as you
were kind of saying seems like they've
made some improvement so if you like the
first search you'll be pretty happy with
it
uh-huh if you didn't like the first
search doesn't seem like it's gonna make
you change your mind all that much yeah
it's it's kind of like the that's
probably a bad comparison cuz one is so
much better than the other but like the
differences between Dark Souls 2 in Dark
Souls 3 they're kind of the exact same
game like combat wise like that was like
just like combat arts and like a few
other changes to combat to just make it
a little bit easier and a little bit
better so it's kind of like that so you
know can you enjoyed the first surge or
if you were interested in getting it and
you just never got around to it you
might as well just start with search - I
don't think it's gonna relate too much
to the story of the first ones I don't
think I have to play the first one to
get into this one yeah cool all right
well thanks for joining us guys and we
will see you tomorrow at 11 a.m. Pacific
time with another video game game
something I guess